And now I'm in position
to talk about what
is the maximum force.
If I push F harder, as if I push
F and the blocks go together,
the accelerations are the same.
I push F harder.
Accelerations are the same.
I push F harder, and
I push F so hard,
that the static friction
no longer reaches
its maximum value.
And if I push F
harder than that,
I will not have--
the static friction
can't get bigger, and the
blocks 1 and 2 will start
to slip relative to each other.
So my no slipping condition
is that I want two things.
a1 equals a2.
We'll call that a.
And the maximum force
condition is that F static
is equal to maximum value.
Now, what is the normal force
between that we refer to
in our fiction law?
There's two normal
forces-- the ground
and the normal force
between the surfaces.
But the static friction
that we're talking about
is between the surfaces.
So that's why we use N
here and not N ground.
And now I can solve
for this F max.
By the way, we also have the
condition that fk is mu k.
What normal force
are we talking about?
N, which we've
called N ground 1.
And now I look at my
equations, and my goal
is to solve for F. I know
Ng1 from this equation.
It's just equal to M1g plus N.
I Know N from that equation.
So Ng1 is just the sum
of the masses times g.
So I know this.
I have f, which is m2a.
And I can now apply my result.
So what we'll do is we'll solve
for the a's, a1 equals a2,
in terms of F max.
So over here we have
that a is f over m2.
That's from this equation.
And now I'll substitute
a1 is equal to that.
I'll substitute that there.
And I get that F
Max is going to be
equal to fk plus f static max.
That's that one.
Plus m1 times a1, which is
f static max divided by m2.
And so I get that
F max equals-- now
I'm going to substitute
in all of these values.
It's going to look a
little complicated.
And so I'd like to have a
little space here for that,
to get everything in here.
And we'll see that it's equal
to mu k m1 plus m2g, fk, mu k,
plus m1 2mg plus f static max
times 1 plus and m1 over m2.
But f static max is
mu N, and N is m2g.
So I get m2g times
1 plus m1 over m2.
And there is, if I push
any harder than that,
block 2 will slip with
respect to block 1.
Again, all of our terms have
the dimensions of acceleration.
This is dimensionless-- 1,
dimensions of acceleration.
And we did miss
one little thing.
We missed the coefficient
of static friction.
And there we have
it, a tricky problem.